[Música]
remezón político en Francia el gobierno
del presidente Manuel macón tuvo la
decisión de aprobar el proyecto de
reforma al sistema de pensiones francés
Con la activación del artículo 49
párrafo 3 y pasando de largo de la
votación de la asamblea nacional en esta
instancia parlamentaria el proyecto no
contaba con garantías para obtener los
votos necesarios para su aprobación en
donde Sí fue aprobado fue en el senado
más detalles en el siguiente reportaje
que fue preparado por la redacción de
France 24 veamos
primero fue el Sí en el senado francés y
luego el gobierno impidió el debate en
la asamblea nacional al inicio de la
sesión cuando ya se conocía la decisión
Del ejecutivo tras la filtración a un
medio de comunicación los diputados de
la oposición empezaron a entonar la
marsellesa
[Aplausos]
la primera ministra Elizabeth born
finalmente invocó el artículo 49-3 de la
Constitución para dar luz verde a la
reforma pensional del gobierno de Manuel
macrón
no podemos jugarnos el futuro de
nuestras pensiones esta reforma es
necesaria por lo tanto sobre la base del
artículo 49 párrafo tres de la
Constitución comprometo la
responsabilidad de mi gobierno sobre el
conjunto del proyecto de ley de la
Reforma de seguridad Social para 2023
modificado por la enmienda de
coordinación comunicada a la asamblea
nacional
Pero qué es este artículo Y por qué le
da esta potestad al gobierno el Primer
Ministro podrá previa deliberación del
Consejo de ministros comprometer la
responsabilidad del gobierno ante la
asamblea nacional en la votación de un
proyecto de ley de finanzas o de
financiación de la seguridad social en
este caso el proyecto de ley se
considerará adoptado A menos que se
apruebe una moción de censura
en las 24 horas siguientes el Primer
Ministro podrá además recurrir a este
procedimiento para otro proyecto o
proposición de ley por periodo de
sesiones de este modo al menos diez
partes del total de la asamblea nacional
deben ponerse de acuerdo para presentar
una moción de censura en las 24 horas
posteriores a la aplicación del artículo
una moción que luego debe ser ratificada
por la mayoría absoluta del parlamento
para hacer caer al gobierno este jueves
El Ejecutivo marcó otro hito ya que es
la vez número 100 que se aplica el 49-3
en la quinta República concretamente
Elizabeth born es la segunda jefa de
gobierno que más veces lo ha puesto en
marcha 11
ahora la asamblea y las calles tendrán
que dar su palabra sobre el
controvertido proyecto de ley que
pretende aumentar la edad de jubilación
de los 62 a los 64 años y que ha
movilizado a millones de personas contra
la propuesta desde hace semanas
pues ya lo ven ustedes en las imágenes
la medida adoptada por el gobierno ha
provocado la ira de los sindicatos en
Francia desde ya convocaron a protestas
en las calles de las ciudades francesas
en señal de rechazo a esta decisión Por
supuesto impopular que fue adoptada por
la administración Mako qué costo
político entonces tiene esta decisión
para el presidente Mako y para la
primera ministra Elizabeth el
descontento social Es evidente entre la
sociedad francesa entonces queda la
pregunta sobre la mesa es esta La chispa
que encenderá manifestaciones sociales a
gran escala en Francia qué dicen
entonces los sindicatos y que dicen los
jóvenes que ya de por sí tienen
condiciones laborales precarias Y cómo
van a proyectar su posible jubilación en
unas décadas más adelante con la reforma
y con esa cambio que va a tener la
estructura de las pensiones en Francia
como también aprovecha esta coyuntura la
oposición política francesa esto apenas
está comenzando y este es el debate de
France 24 y para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a florian la farge él es
analista político ex consejero del
Vocero del gobierno francés entre los
años 2015 y 2017 él se conecta desde la
ciudad de la paz en Bolivia y desde la
ciudad de Bogotá en Colombia se conectan
Nicolás Murillo coordinador del
instituto de altos estudios para el
desarrollo de la universidad externado
en Colombia en la ciudad de Bogotá
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de este debate ustedes ya lo saben
pero se lo recuerdo ustedes pueden dejar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales estamos en Twitter
en Facebook y también en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f24 a
mí me encuentran en Twitter como arroba
santilogo ya para el cierre les recuerdo
que también estamos disponibles en
nuestras diferentes plataformas de
podcast por ejemplo Apple podcast
Spotify deezer y en TuneIn
bueno comienzo entonces dándole la
bienvenida a florian en la ciudad de la
paz en Bolivia florián Gracias por estar
con nosotros en el programa y Punto de
partida para comenzar la discusión y el
análisis sobre estos hechos ocurridos en
Francia había alguna alternativa al uso
de este artículo para ser aprobado este
proyecto de ley el presidente
llegó a una especie de callejón sin
salida y tuvo que sacar bajo la manga
este artículo de la Constitución para
poder aprobar esta propuesta de reforma
al sistema de pensiones
Sí pues primero quería decir todo eso
para eso porque llevamos meses entonces
de debates en la asamblea en el senado y
para preparar también la población para
para estar en forma yo creo que había
varias otras vías Primero era una
concertación un poco más amplia con los
sindicatos porque al final lo que vimos
este macron prefirió el diálogo con el
partido de los republicanos que con la
cfdt que es el principal sindicato en
Francia que es un un sindicato
reformador digamos
su equivocación su error fue Entonces no
tener un diálogo a profundidad con este
sindicato lo que tuvo como consecuencia
de lanzarlo en la calle en concentración
con nosotros sindicatos lo que dio la
fuerza a una Unión sindical y que lanzó
mucha gente en la calle después de eso
también yo creo que hay un descontento
por una incomprensión de la población
sobre esta reforma una incomprensión que
es totalmente legítima dando el hecho si
hay un desequilibrio un desequilibrio
entre el esfuerzo entre el capital y el
trabajo y ahí para mí habían dos
reformas que se podían hacer que no
fueron tomadas por el gobierno era
aumentar la contribución por ejemplo
para el reembolso de la tribudad social
que impacta los ingresos de capital y
que no ha aumentado desde
1996 y segundo quizás será también
aumenta la contribución social general
para las pensiones más elevadas con el
fin de mantener una cierta solidaridad
solidaridad generacional porque aquí lo
que estamos haciendo es pedir nuevamente
un esfuerzo a los trabajadores en una
reforma más tomando cuenta que ya
hicieron muchos esfuerzos en tiempo de
covid y no a los pensionados y los
pensionados actualmente en Francia Son
los que tienen el poder adquisitivo el
más elevado aquí estamos formando que no
está entendido pasamos ahora a darle la
bienvenida a Nicolás Murillo en la
ciudad de Bogotá Nicolás Gracias por
estar con nosotros en el programa y el
mismo Punto de partida la misma pregunta
había alguna otra alternativa o Esto fue
el único as bajo la manga que tenía el
presidente macón Para poder llevar
adelante esta reforma que como dicen en
su gobierno es completamente necesaria y
eso ya lo vamos a analizar más adelante
bienvenido Muchas gracias muchas gracias
por invitarme también bueno para para
complementar lo que dijo el señor les lo
que pasa es que este gobierno ha
mostrado desde el desde el inicio que no
está dispuesto a dialogar no escucha la
calle no escucha la población Y en este
caso pues no cambió no cambió el
panorama el cargo de 493 fue utilizado
varias veces ya no es una novedad no es
sorprendente ahora bien otras opciones
existen claro el diálogo tratar de de
mitigar de tratar de escuchar digamos la
reivindicaciones de la calle en cuanto a
en cuanto a la situación de las mujeres
de la situación de las personas que
trabajan desde antes
desde digamos muy jóvenes
tratar de entender digamos o o trabajar
a favor del de la solidaridad y no O al
menos la sensación que da es trabajar a
favor de ciertas categorías sociales
es ese es el punto fundamental es que no
no hubo un diálogo real
en esencia entonces Nicolás continuó con
usted aquí el error grande no fue
presentar una reforma y hacer una gran
apuesta a modificar la cantidad de los
cobros la edad de jubilación este tipo
de de factores que es lo que la gente
está reclamando ahora en la calle sino a
verlo comunicado de una manera correcta
haberse reunido con los sindicatos y
haber conversado también con la
oposición sobre esta necesidad de
reformar el sistema de acuerdo a lo que
dice el gobierno para el 2030 el sistema
de pensiones franceses estaría
desfinanciado por unos 12.500 millones
de euros si no se hace una reforma en
este momento el error fue esto
información diálogo y ponerlo en común
pues más que más que información Creo
que este sobre todo
trabajar para encontrar soluciones que
fuera que fueran más equilibradas para
la población porque como lo dije antes
la reforma que está aquí es una reforma
que
atropella los derechos de muchas
personas y habría otras propuestas que
se hicieron desde desde la oposición que
se hicieron incluso desde desde el
organismo republicanos sino ni siquiera
estas fueron totalmente digamos acogidas
por el gobierno Entonces como lo hizo
desde desde que fue reelegido está
pasando en fuerza como como siempre
convencido de que está en la verdad Y
que todos los demás Simplemente no
entienden la reforma es necesaria todos
estamos de acuerdo pero el problema es
la forma de que toma la reforma y los
parámetros está tomando en cuenta
florian su opinión una reforma entonces
podemos decir poco equitativa poco
balanceada
es decir que ahorita estamos tomando en
cuenta O sea dentro en el marco de esta
de esta reforma los esfuerzos están
concentrando únicamente sobre los
trabajadores es un poco lo que decía
previamente
hubieran podido abrir un poco la reforma
a otros
otras fuentes para financiar justamente
es este déficit Yo no niego que exista
un déficit
además fue un error de comunicación
desde el principio porque el gobierno
decía que era Entre 10 15 20 billones de
de euros y al final resultó que eran 13
13 millones de euros sobre un sistema de
salud pública un sistema de pensión no
es tanto la verdad Y entonces se podría
encontrar otras fuentes de de
financiamientos
todos se recalca sobre los trabajadores
en esta reforma yo creo que ahí si
querían un equilibrio si querían
negociar con los sindicatos si querían
de verdad dar todas todos los elementos
todos estos actores para lograr esta
reforma y tener una votación dentro de
las asamblea que abrir la puerta con
otras fuentes de financiamiento con el
capital o también hacer contribuir los
pensionados que ya repito son las
personas que tienen el mejor poder
adquisitivo en la República francesa
Entonces si queremos de verdad tener una
victoria sobre esta reforma había que
hacer un equilibrio nuevo sobre esta
reforma El problema es que como se
hallado con el partido los republicanos
fue una una reforma más conservadora y
más liberal a uno y es lo que resulta
hoy creo que es importante contarle a la
audiencia de France 24 en América Latina
el papel que tienen los sindicatos en
Francia Nicolás son un eje
importantísimo en la política en las
elecciones en el día a día de Francia y
de esas luchas sociales que han llevado
a cabo a lo largo de los años muchas de
las conquistas que tiene este país a
nivel social se ha dado a través de las
luchas sindicales
Por qué en este escenario los sindicatos
no fueron tenidos en cuenta porque si
hay un país en donde los sindicatos son
representativos es Francia
bueno representativos de de ciertas de
ciertas categorías socio profesionales
seguro las los liberales las profesiones
liberales no no están muy muy muy muy
digamos muy metidas en este tema pero el
como lo dije antes la situación
actualmente es que tenemos una un
sistema una una forma de gobernar que no
es que no es absolutamente la escucha de
lo que se dice ni siquiera en el
parlamento es una especie de de
polarización permanente y de y de y de
bloqueo de bloqueo político no no no hay
absolutamente ningún tipo de negociación
real entre la entre las partes y los lo
que ocurre lo que ocurrió en los
cuarenta y nueve tres anteriores es que
simplemente negocian con el partido que
les permite tener la mayoría Entonces se
escuchan solamente a un partido a una
una fuente que es los republicanos y
negocian exclusivamente casi con ellos
Entonces los sindicatos terminan siendo
una minoría como todo el resto
florián su opinión
bueno Aquí yo creo que hay que ver
también un poco Quiénes son los
perdedores de esta reforma porque
efectivamente son numerosos y yo creo
que el hecho de hallarse nada más con
los republicanos que efectivamente no
representan muchas personas a
fragilizado este este gobierno Entonces
primero como lo habías dicho mi mi
colega
es asamblea nacional porque dio la
prueba de su ingobernabilidad y su
incapacidad a encontrar
consenso
segundo para mí esta oposición porque
claramente no ha logrado captar el 70%
de la oposición de la población a estar
en forma y por sus postura no se
construye una alternativa creíble al día
de hoy y Tenían un Bulevar para tener
esta autoposición y y recuperar este
electorado tenía la opción de debatir
sobre el fondo de esta reforma y ha
bloqueado al proceso la consecuencia es
que ha tocado el fondo de la peor
política el partido de para mí también
es uno de los partidos que ha perdido
más en este proceso porque acaba de
demostrar su explosión en dos partes
la reforma misma que ha perdido Porque
será visto como ilegítima por el uso
justamente de cuarenta y nueve punto
tres
y los sindicatos que no han podido
demostrar la fuerza necesaria para
impedir la aplicación de esta ley y como
justamente lo ha dicho mi colega esto
sindicatos no representan toda la
población en Francia el 7% de la
población está sin siquiera fiscalizada
Entonces es muy poco y el gobierno cuyo
apoyo popular ha bajado un montón y no
logró convencer la población por su mala
comunicación durante todo este proceso
hay que recordar una cosa y me parece
que es importante es que son dos mil
días que estamos viviendo sobre este
tema de de la Reforma de las pensiones
desde la nominación
a las pensiones y medios cinco años y
medio después estamos llegando a este a
este fin con el uso de cuarenta y nueve
punto tres que es la peor cosa
pero viendo viendo aquí un poco el
escenario florián continuó con usted
esta fue una de las promesas de campaña
del presidente macron para su reelección
para su segundo mandato aquí entonces
cómo se puede analizar la situación está
cumpliendo con su plan de campaña
por haber quedado como presidente que
fue lo que le hicieron los franceses
aunque él mismo dijo en su momento que
sabía que su programa no fue lo que
compraron los votantes franceses A la
hora de elegir sino que fue un voto en
contra de aquí Entonces como entiende
uno esta situación
exactamente
fue elegido a la primera vuelta por un
un veinticuatro por ciento más o menos
de la población veinticuatro por ciento
que podemos pensar que la mayor parte de
este 24% está apoyando firmemente su
programa pero las demás que han votado
para él después a la segunda vuelta
obviamente no están a favor de su
programa está nada más suponía industria
la extrema derecha que para recordarlo
han ganado un 41% lo que fue muchísimo
pero del punto de vista de macron ahora
es la única verdadera reforma que él ha
defendido dentro de su programa no
acabar no aplicar esta reforma sería
acabar con su nuevo quinquenado es decir
que después no tendría más oxígeno no
tendría más aire para sobrepasar esta
etapa y para tener una nueva página para
su presidencia
y también hay otro evento que se viene a
pegar sobre la situación actual Es que
yo creo que también está jugando una
situación Internacional del mercado
financiero rechazar esta reforma
demostrar a los mercados internacionales
que no puede hacer nada frente a su
propia población sería dar una mala
señal en cuanto a las notaciones de las
grandes agencias de notación como
tiempo entonces por eso que está quizás
afirmando su poder por el 49.3 claro de
alguna forma de pronto también se está
blindando a nivel económico a nivel
internacional Nicolás su opinión sobre
sobre este punto que destaca florián
Pues digamos que
el el la situación de macron es la misma
de siempre cuando cuando fue elegido fue
elegido efectivamente por veinticuatro
por ciento de la población su programa
como tal no tiene el apoyo de la de la
de la de los ciudadanos él cuando fue
elegido mencionó que estaba que era
consciente de esto pero su actitud Al
momento de gobernar muestra
absolutamente otra cosa y la situación
es grave porque al hacer eso está
favoreciendo digamos el descontento
popular frente a las instituciones la
desconfianza frente a la clase política
frente a las elecciones como tal Y esta
está poniéndole un camino un camino
derecho un camino de oro a los partidos
extremos Entonces el costo político para
él no mucho pero el costo político para
el país se puede ser en orden este yo
estoy de acuerdo Es probable que su su
su su su su su su su voluntad sea
digamos de devolverla de devolver la
confianza de los mercados financieros
hacia la economía francesa pero al mismo
tiempo está creando una especie de
de hoyo negro en el que no sabemos no
sabemos hasta dónde podemos podemos caer
Nicolás así las cosas como ustedes lo
explican este mensaje que manda el
presidente macron con esta decisión y
con esta acción
que ha tomado recientemente en cuanto a
la activación de este artículo de la
Constitución pone un punto final o
simplemente pone puntos suspensivos y
reitera ese mensaje
de fortalecer a su oposición política de
Cara a próximos comicios o esto Qué
mensaje le está mandando a los franceses
y también a la Unión Europea porque
tenemos que hablar del peso que tiene
Francia dentro de la Unión Europea y lo
que esto va a tener eco en los otros 26
países
Bueno pues creo que el mensaje es claro
el mensaje es voy a ir hasta el final no
me importa
fundamentalmente creo que ese es el
mensaje general que no que nos está
dando ahora bien yo lo que podemos
esperar básicamente es que
los republicanos que son finalmente la
el grupo clave en este momento tengan
conciencia de de lo que está pasando que
la emoción de censura sea la solución
será evidentemente sería raro pero pues
podemos esperarlo y generaría una
necesidad de pronto de de de construir
otro tipo de relación con la oposición
ahora bien para la Unión Europea pues
probablemente probablemente un poco
preocupante porque como lo dije antes la
economía francesa está está paralizada
de alguna manera afecta afecta
enormemente la Unión Europea y a
términos políticos lo que puede salir de
esto es un gobierno antigua priísta
entonces pues yo personalmente estoy muy
preocupado
antieuropedista cuando justamente la
Unión Europea le está pidiendo le está
pidiendo un gran liderazgo en Europa
países como Francia y Alemania que son
países que ahorita tienen una una
relación un poco distante cierro este
esta Arista de el tema del presidente y
paso a hablar de la oposición que va a
ser fundamental Y seguramente vamos a
estar hablando de los pasos que van a ir
dando a lo largo de las próximas horas y
días Aquí la única manera que Tal parece
que tiene la oposición para rechazar
esta propuesta y y esta decisión es la
moción de censura contra el gobierno que
debe ser presentada en un espacio de 24
horas florián esto es viable este
mecanismo tiene podrá tener desarrollo y
llegar al puerto que quiere llegar la
oposición para bloquear esto o
simplemente hará el intento pero morirá
en el intento
tiene tres opciones la primera
Efectivamente es en el marco del
artículo
49.3 es accionar una moción de censura
Entonces si la mayoría de la asamblea
vota esta mención de de censura ahí se
cayera
se va a caer Entonces el Gobierno no
tiene otra opción porque el gobierno
está dando su responsabilidad frente a
la asamblea accionando este artículo es
imposible que esto resulte por qué
Porque justamente hoy mismo los
republicanos justamente han dicho que no
iban a votar ninguna mención de censura
y las dos oposiciones de extrema
izquierda y extrema derecha no están lo
suficientemente numerosos para poder
esta esta mención de censura Entonces yo
descarto esta esta primera opción la
segunda opción para mí que me parece la
más importante y la y quizás la más
inteligente además para la oposición
teoría solicitar la firma de 60
diputados para solicitar ante el consejo
constitucional el pronunciarse sobre la
validez de pasar dicha ley de tal
actitud en el marco de un proyecto de
ley de financiamiento rectificado de
seguridad social ahí sería interesante
de ver justamente la viabilidad de
presentar de integrar esta reforma de
pensiones Dentro de este proyecto de ley
de financiamiento rectificado y tercer
tercera opción es quizás el escenario de
un cpe que yo lo mencionaba así el
cepillo reforma de
2006 fue promulgada pero que nunca fue
aplicada por la presión de la que ayer
entonces a ver ahora la movilización en
las calles a ver si efectivamente el
gobierno va a retroceder y como muy bien
lo dijo Nicolás Yo creo que es casi
imposible porque tenemos un gobierno que
está hasta ahora muy
al diálogo pero por si acaso por si
acaso llegamos a este escenario
Efectivamente es la única opción que yo
veo viable es segunda movilización que
vamos tener de hecho ya los sindicatos
se han pronunciado para movilizarse el
23 de marzo
interesante esos tres escenarios que
usted nos explica florian Nicolás cuál
ve usted de estos tres que propone
florián son los tres escenarios más
viables O el más viable y si usted
quiere Añadir otro posible Bienvenido al
debate también ese comentario No pues lo
que dijo Florencia cierto lo que el
problema bueno primero retroceder por la
calle tocaría de verdad que la
movilización fuera una de libertad hacia
afuera de la Revolución siempre sí
Exacto el tema de la emoción censura
parece muy poco probable y el tema del
Consejo Perdón del del Consejo
constitucional también es un es un es un
análisis de forma Entonces
es poco también es poco probable digamos
que que que que que que que que funcione
porque como lo dijeron ustedes al inicio
este reportaje existe digamos este esta
mención de que de que el 49:3 puede ser
usado por temas de financiamiento pero
pues Digamos si esta esta sería de la la
el el el el el chaleco salvavidas
en el caso de que el consejo
constitucional pudiera bloquear esta
esta reforma bueno De acuerdo a lo que
ustedes están analizando Nicolás florián
uno podría
pensar que el escenario está a favor del
presidente y a favor de la decisión que
ha tomado con su gobierno Pese a que
puede presentarse algunas piedras en el
camino pero Tal parece que entonces esta
reforma va para adelante y va a llegar a
hacer puesta en marcha por por este
gobierno en esta coyuntura como
capitaliza la la oposición francesa ese
descontento social y ese ese desatino
porque así lo han calificado algunos
analistas de esta decisión del
presidente y del gobierno ya ustedes lo
mencionaban la oposición está con
algunos puntos fraccionadas los
republicanos dijeron que no van a votar
Esa esa moción de censura no hay
consenso en eso pero es un momento para
fortalecerse para unirse o lo están
dejando pasar y lo están desaprovechando
porque en la política cada minuto cada
segundo y cada coyuntura se aprovecha
florián
Bueno capitalizar sobre esta protesta yo
creo que no han demostrado justamente su
ineficiencia y su debilidad en el marco
de los debates yo creo que están hasta
ridiculizado entonces ya están unidos de
hecho porque preguntaba si se podían
unir la izquierda ya está unida dentro
del parlamento se llama la nupes no
Entonces yo creo que no han recuperado
los frutos de esta movilización al
contrario yo creo que más bien fue
fueron los sindicatos y particularmente
la cfd que es el sindicato deformista
que fue
al liderazgo de esta protesta que más
bien había pedido justamente a los
políticos hacen de hacer su trabajo y de
ir hacia el final del debate dentro de
la asamblea nacional porque hay que
recordar que la asamblea nacional no
pudo lograr terminar acabar los debates
y ha pasado el texto directamente al
senado
después los que pueden capitalizar Sí
ahí dentro de la oposición
nacional que es la extrema derecha lo
que me preocupa también y aquí estoy de
acuerdo con mi colega me parece un
escenario preocupante la recuperación
política por la extrema derecha por qué
Porque ya hemos vivido este tipo de
escenario en Europa y justamente en
Italia y en Italia tuvieron este mismo
tipo de reforma de pensiones y ha dado
los resultados que conocemos hoy en día
es decir que la derecha ha disfrutado ha
aprovechado de estas reformas para
reforzarse no fue el único factor pero
también ha contribuido a reforzar la
extrema derecha
Nicolás su opinión es todo está
reforzando la extrema derecha como lo
dice florián y esto le está entregando
de mano a mano o en bandeja las
elecciones presidenciales de unos
cuantos años a futuro a esta a esta a
esta parte del espectro político Pues sí
claramente Sí porque el cansancio
digamos la la crisis de
representatividad que que tenemos en
este momento en Francia la crisis de
confianza hacia las instituciones y y la
sensación de que sea cual sea el
gobierno que que elijamos tenemos el
mismo resultado y gobiernan para los
mismos no sé si es cierto o no pero las
sensaciones real y la población poco a
poco pues está yéndose hasta los hacia
los votos de protesta y los votos de
protesta favorecen líderes que a pesar
de hablar de decir ves cosas que son
ridículas como lo dijo flojo terminar
captando por la facilidad y por la
simpleza de su de su de sus argumentos
también captando la gente que no está de
acuerdo que está que está enfadada y el
voto enfadado Es peligroso porque
termina eligiendo a personas muy
peligrosas en este caso yo pienso
efectivamente también era la razón
nacional y a mediano plazo eso como
afecta la democracia francesa
Pues el problema es que nosotros tenemos
una constitución como lo hemos visto en
los últimos meses que favorece la
gobernabilidad frente a la
representatividad entonces en el a
partir del momento en que el gobierno
tiene las herramientas para pasar por
encima del parlamento como lo hemos
visto y eso pues fue la Constitución de
un género de Gol entonces una
constitución que favorece al presidente
es un es un rey en ejercicio un rey
elegido que se puede afectar muchísimo
porque pues pueden pasar pasar normas
muy muy muy muy muy muy muy muy digamos
muy
antiderechos humanos por decirlo así Y
de alguna forma si pasa por encima de
una de una decisión y de algunas
instancias políticas allá en Francia
florian su opinión sobre cómo esto puede
afectar a mediano plazo la democracia
francesa y también el uso que se le ha
dado en Francia a este artículo 49.3 ya
lo decíamos en el informe en la
introducción del programa Esta es la vez
número 100 que ha sido utilizado por el
gobierno de turno para poder mover algo
algún tipo de reforma o proyecto a
través de este mecanismo
Sí ese artículo está criticado por todos
los partidos y mientras tanto todos los
partidos lo usan Así que claro siempre
está culpable de falta de democracia
este artículo y resulta ser necesario
para muchas reformas no es
inconstitucional es dentro de la
Constitución de la Constitución Francesa
y tiene un propósito muy interesante es
que incluso esta esta Constitución fue
para evitar los disturbios dentro de la
asamblea nacional que teníamos con la
cuarta república donde no se avanzaba
ningún proyecto de ley por falta de
mayoría Entonces es como la la última
arma para el gobierno para imponer un
proyecto de ley cuando y solamente
cuando es para un solo proyecto de ley
en la agenda de un año de la asamblea
nacional o para proyectos de
financiamientos de presupuesto hay que
destacar también que este este artículo
fue en 2009 si si no me equivoco
justamente para limitar su uso y evitar
un abuso del cuarenta y nueve punto tres
entonces no creo que sea eso en sí que
está debilitando la democracia francesa
pero es más bien la falta de
concertación que tuvieron desde el
principio de esta reforma con los
sindicatos
de la Democracia es que no hubo debate y
no hubo socialización con los sindicatos
y yo creo que eso fue lo más grave para
el gobierno que tuvo que sacar este
cuarenta y nueve punto tres y que hace
que esta ley pueda ser visto por el
pueblo como una una reforma que no sea
legítima y deja un mal precedente para
para la sociedad hemos hablado de los
sindicatos hemos hablado de la oposición
del presidente y hay un sector de la
sociedad francesa que me parece
importante analizar qué es lo que le
viene en su futuro
cercano y es los jóvenes franceses
muchos de ellos cómo van a ser parte de
este nuevo sistema de pensiones cuando
ya tiene unas condiciones laborales
precarias cuando ya Los sueldos son
insuficientes y así lo lo reprochan
muchos y el paro juvenil o esa cantidad
de jóvenes que hay preparados formados
con estudios académicos de alto nivel y
no encuentran trabajo es una realidad
que no solamente tiene Francia sino
varios países de la Unión Europea esto
aquí como encaja florián en esta reforma
esta gente que futuro le espera
no el futuro hay dos cosas primero Es
dependiendo también de la demografía
francesa si la demografía se mantiene a
un nivel muy bajo Obviamente que los
déficits van a crecer y que otras
reformas van a tener que van a tener que
estar tomadas o
encontrar otras fuentes de
financiamiento aquí lo que me preocupa
más es la ruptura de solidaridad
generacional entre los jóvenes y y los
mayores es lo que había un poco tocado
como tema al principio es que los
jóvenes los trabajadores son los que más
han dado de esfuerzos con fino haciendo
el confinamiento no para los las
personas mayores sacrificando un poco su
vida para permitir a estas personas de
sobrevivir y evitar la contaminación de
todos y hoy mismo estamos pidiendo lo
mismo Además de eso estamos con una
desigualdad con una fuerte inflación los
trabajadores no están siguiendo su
sueldo no la inflación mientras que las
pensiones de los mayores está indexada
justamente sobre la inflación Entonces
tenemos mayores que ya tienen un poder
adquisitivo mayor porque han vivido un
periodo de oro con casi cero desempleo
con tasas para para comprar su casa de
casi Cero en la época etcétera y que
entonces ahora viven bien y estamos
pidiendo a los jóvenes que están
luchando con más desempleo con la
inflación de hacer aún más esfuerzos
ni mi inquietudes eso es la ruptura de
la solidaridad
intergeneracional Nicolás su opinión
sobre este tema
Pues yo entiendo la preocupación de los
jóvenes no no han empezado a trabajar y
ya les estamos diciendo que que tendrán
que trabajar en con peores condiciones y
más tiempo porque la realidad es esta
hoy en día tenemos una un déficit de
empleos pero que que afecta también a
los mayores es muy curioso esto que no
se tengan que no se que no esté en el en
el discurso del gobierno que no tenga en
cuenta lo que me preocupa a mí es esto
los dos extremos de la pirámide de de
edades van a estar van a estar en
dificultad porque sabemos que el empleo
mayor en Francia de los mayores es es
muy muy muy muy muy muy muy muy muy
precario y el de los jóvenes también es
lo que yo pienso es que vamos a tener
una situación insostenible en el futuro
para mediano plazo en 2030
vamos llegando ya el bloque final de el
programa Nicolás florián debo hacer las
conclusiones de lo que sigue entonces en
el desarrollo de esta propuesta para que
se haya puesta en marcha en Francia y lo
que sigue para el presidente macron y
para la política de este país comienzo
con florián y dejó Nicolás para el
cierre del programa floriana adelante
y cuál es esa pregunta Disculpa la
conclusión lo que viene de ahora en
adelante para para para esta situación
para este proyecto para el presidente y
para el gobierno en Sí sí Entonces para
mí es un empate es decir gobierno está
debilitado y yo creo que la posición y
los sindicatos también perdido en esta
operación la primera ministra está la
primera persona que está perdiendo va a
querer seguir después de eso yo no sé es
un fracaso ella tiene que tomar estar
esta responsabilidad porque vendió su
reforma bajo la modalidad de un diálogo
amplio y es un diálogo que fracasó del
lado de macron cambiar de Primer
Ministro sí quizás pero para hacer que Y
con quién Nadie puede apostar sobre una
persona que podría reemplazar a
Elizabeth y es el principio de su de su
fin que era entonces tener que cambiar
tan rápidamente de Primer Ministro sería
mandar una muy mala señal claro y
Nicolás para el cierre de Broche el
programa su conclusión
es que se viene una un periodo de
inestabilidad política bastante bastante
preocupante sobre todo en tiempos de de
guerra y de y de y de y de crisis
internacional es probable que las
personas no dejen de salir de la calle
que los Perdón universitarios los
sindicatos los sectores socios
profesionales afectados no van a dejar
de protestar Y si el gobierno no sigue
con la misma línea de de de no
negociación Entonces no sé qué podrá que
podrá pasar la parálisis económica puede
ser una realidad y bueno no creo que sea
digamos no creo que acabe con el país
pero sí sí puede ser muy turbulenta y
afectar la inversión afectar todo lo que
tiene que ver con con el crecimiento
pues como lo decía yo en la introducción
del programa esto apenas está comenzando
si ustedes creían que ya habíamos visto
todo en esta remezón político en Francia
esto apenas inicia a Nicolás y a florián
les agradezco mucho por este análisis y
por habernos explicado habernos puesto
al tanto de la situación política en
Francia para la audiencia de France 24
en América Latina es todo por el momento
En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos su sintonía el día de hoy la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Andrés doncel y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera Pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]